-The last time you were here
I believe was
right before
last year's Golden Globes.
-Yes.
And I wished you lucked
and then it worked.
-Yes.
You were the good luck charm.
-You won.
-Because of you
that happened.
-Thank you very much.
Well, 'cause you didn't thank me
during your speech
so I wanted to make sure
you remember.
[ Laughter ]
-I wanted to do it here live
right to your face
and look right in your eyes and
say, thank you, Seth.
-This is better.
This is better.
-It's more meaningful this way.
-Since
"People Versus O.J. Simpson,"
which was -- from last year
one of the most special moments
in television,
have you -- have people
approached you more?
Has that performance --
-Yeah.
I think "American Horror Story"
is a more niche thing
and the O.J. thing
had a wider net.
-Yeah.
-But not as much -- not as
far-reaching as I thought
because I was on the phone
the other day in the airport,
and a very nice girl
came up to me
and tapped me on the shoulder,
and said,
"I don't want to interrupt you."
And of course I thought,
"Well, then don't --
don't interrupt me."
[ Laughter ]
And she said, "I just wanted to
give you this."
And it was
a little cocktail napkin.
I looked down
and it said,
"Hi, Ms. Foy. I think
you're the greatest actress."
And I was like,
"She thinks I'm Claire Foy."
I was like, my career is not --
the needle hasn't moved at all.
-No.
-Nobody knows who I am.
-Well, Claire Foy
is very talented.
-Sure. And also, much younger
than I am, so I'll take it.
-Yeah, take those napkins.
-Yeah.
I took the napkin.
-When life gives you
that gift of a napkin...
-I actually went to her and I
was like, "Did you --
Do you want to save this
for when you do run into
Claire Foy?"
And she's like,
"No, you can keep it."
And so I kept it.
I thought it would be a good --
-You should have written on one,
"I'm a huge fan of yours,
Sarah Paulson,"
And gave it to her and said,
"this is for Claire Foy."
-Give this to her next time.
-When you ever meet her.
-Yeah, exactly.
-So, this -- "The Post" is --
This is one of those fantastic
films about journalism,
and it's very timely now.
It's about very earlier '70s and
The Washington Post's decision
to publish the Pentagon papers.
-Yes, because our government
was not operating from a place
of full transparency.
-Yeah, it's weird.
-It's so weird
that it's relevant now.
-Yeah, it totally came back.
-It's strange.
-That came back around.
-Yeah, that's somehow full
circle and here we are again.
-You had read Katharine Graham's
autobiography.
-Yes, called "Personal History,"
when I was about 26 years old,
and I tried to option it.
They were not interested
in letting me have it.
So, I was pretty well-versed
about her and her life,
and she's an incredible woman.
First woman on the Fortune 500
list to, you know --
C.E.O., it was just incredible.
And was it a fantastic --
it must have been a fantastic
thing to be part of.
-Well, you know,
it's Steven Spielberg.
So, when you get that call
you're sort of going,
"Do I do it, do I not do it?
It's Steven Spielberg."
And then it's, like,
it's also Tom Hanks.
You play his wife,
and some lady named Meryl Streep
who's at the beginning
of her career
and it's just starting out
for her.
We're not sure
where it's gonna go.
-Well, still you can always say
you were in her first movie.
-I was in her first movie.
And I think -- I can tell you
that I think things
are gonna go well for her.
-I want to ask about
"American Horror Story."
So, this is --
How many now have you done?
-I've done seven seasons.
-Seven seasons.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This season you had one of
the more normal looks
you've had on the shows.
Is that a safe --
-Yes, that's a safe thing
to say.
Yeah, normal being that --
-Yeah, you kind of
look like yourself
'cause these are previous years.
This is -- Is this Coven?
-This is Coven.
-Yeah.
-That's just an acid-burn
face look,
if anyone is interested in that.
-Yeah, totally normal.
-Totally normal.
-This is --
-Hotel.
Yeah, Hotel.
-That's Sally the junkie.
-Sally, the junkie.
This is really the coup de gras
right there.
-Yeah, that's
the two-headed gal.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And you got cast as both,
which is --
-I got to play both,
although a lot of people do come
up to me now and they're like,
"Where's your other head?"
-Yeah.
-I'm like...
-"That was Claire Foy."
[ Laughter ]
This look was actually
a scary look
because I would actually go out
after work --
-Which one? Oh, yeah.
-After work I would forget --
People think this is a wig.
It ain't.
-Oh, wow.
-That's my hair.
-Oh, wow. I definitely thought
it was a wig.
-Yeah, yeah, I had to basically
shave it off when it was over
because it was so damaged.
But I would go to
buy milk at the store
at the end of the work day,
and they would, like, drop
my change into my hand,
they didn't want to touch me.
[ Laughter ]
I forgot that
I looked like that.
And I was like,
"What is going on?"
-You, also --
I'm very excited about this --
"Oceans 8" is coming.
-It's coming, and I think --
Yeah, the trailer's coming.
-The trailer's coming very soon.
This is very exciting.
And one of your cast members --
this is a fantastic cast --
Sandra Bullock.
-Cate Blanchett,
Mindy Kaling, Anne Hathaway.
-We talked about it last time
you were here though.
Rihanna is in the film.
-Yeah, just, also, someone at
the beginning of their career.
We're not sure
what she's capable of.
-And you and I both share
a low-level, perfectly legal,
obsession with Rihanna.
-Yeah. And, uh, yeah.
She texted me not long after.
I got a text message
from Rihanna, yeah.
But I was convinced
that there was no --
She sent me like,
a crying/laughing emoji
congratulating me
on winning the Golden Globe.
And I was like, "Rihanna's
not gonna send an emoji.
She's not sending an emoji."
And then I went to set
the next day.
She was like,
"Yes, that was me."
-Wow.
-And I thought,
"I can't believe she texted me."
I haven't heard from her
in a long time, I will say.
-Gotcha. Well, of course not.
She congratulated you
and you iced her.
-Yeah, because I was like,
"I'm not writing back
to this girl
who's pretending to be Rihanna.
I'm totally not going
to do that."
But I do think I have
a little bit of a connection
if you want me to see
if I can't try to get her
to come on your show.
-Look, I don't think
that's going to happen.
But I will take an emoji.
Just get me --
Sarah, get me an emoji.
-I will get
an emoji from Rihanna.
-Even if she has to send it
to you and you forward it to me.
-It should be like,
"This is for Seth."
-Yeah, this emoji.
-Or she'll send me an emoji
and I'll craft something
that's like, "Give this to Seth"
but it won't really be
from Rihanna.
That will be from me.
I'll take anything --
-From Rihanna.
She also sends me
some fenti goodies
every once in awhile, too.
-Your life is fantastic.
-It's pretty cool, yeah.
-How do they -- how -- When
Rihanna sends you something,
does it come via regular mail?
-It, like, comes down
in a giant unicorn
with billowing hair
and diamonds and things.
-There's, like, smoke machines.
-There's, like, a poof and,
like, a wind,
and you're like, "Ahhh"
and it's your UPS guy.
The UPS guy does not wear
normal clothing
when he delivers things.
-The UPS guy delivers it
and then he explodes.
-Then he explodes, yeah.
He's like,
"I think this is from Rihanna."
-He's like, "If this is
how I'm go, I'm happy."
-"Anyone would go this way."
It's true.
-So I want that too.
I want an emoji and just one --
-You want an exploding UPS guy
to hand you
a really exciting thing of fenti
sandals with faux fur on them.
-Golden Globes, Spielberg movie,
seven years of "Horror Story."
None of that means anything --
None of it's as cool
as an emoji from Rihanna.
-I'm going to get text messages
from you now
more frequently
than I already do.
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you so much
for being here.
It's always such a delight
to have you.
Sarah Paulson, everybody.